what's up everybody uh we've been locked
up for a long time and now i'm finally
getting on the road again so i hope to
see you uh and then i will be on tour
solo in des moines indianapolis
cleveland san diego la burlington a
second show added at foxwoods detroit
pittsburgh albany washington dc which is
really tyson's virginia madison
wisconsin and chicago uh all in jan in
february all of those are on sale right
this second at savolcanocomedy.com
can't wait to see you guys god
coming to the bless talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right taste buds man
yeah they're coming to the mic i'm
talking taste buds
hey everybody it is the taste buds
podcast and we are coming back to you i
am sal volcano hi i'm brian quinn
surprise if you're listening and not
watching brian quinn is back to join us
again i think you uh i think you have
are now like i'm seeing the road that's
being traveled i think you're becoming
yeah the thing the number one like the
first
oh
that's great fill in yeah i mean you're
like oh you're like the substitute now i
like that yeah i like that i mean
i like it when it's fans i've been
loving but it's me and you i like it i
don't know if i'm gonna get the the coal
[Laughter]
here we go already uh
we had so um q joining us today again
i guess joe just
a cold as always joe just doesn't
joe joe just doesn't care busy launching
the bar also
unfortunately he had a an exposure so
you're just playing it safe okay so uh
but you know all right we might keep
these in the pocket they might not all
come in succession um we filmed a couple
last week yeah um but you know maybe or
maybe we should just do four in a row
with you and be like it's the q it's the
q month the month of q i like that i
always wanted my own money joe actually
messaged me and said he does not want
that to happen yeah because he does not
want to be overthrown on his own show
yeah
well
joe also
messaged me and i'm not sure is it too
early to jump into these voicemails you
haven't heard them yet no no so let's
tell let's tell our fans
the listeners what we're doing we were
trying to think of what our battles
would be today and q had the brilliant
idea of doing joe derosa versus krista
stefano yeah two members of the no
pressure network of course you know who
joe is because you're watching you
probably know who q is uh because you uh
hopefully you watch both shows
i'm sorry
but uh if you don't chris uh is the
co-host he's a comedian and the co-host
of the hey babe podcast with me also on
this network uh i'm assuming you guys
know because chris is co-hosted and
something very organic to this battle is
that chris and joe have a fun
public feud that's been going on for
months and joe puts up these instagram
things called dis stefano i saw that
there are episodes of him dissing
stefano and then chris of course is just
relentless with joe all the time as well
so they go at it all the time so we're
kind of throwing it to the fans today
yeah yeah
yeah and i have the uh the honor of uh
defending uh derosa it wouldn't be right
if i defended de rosa in the podcast
where i go up against derozan yeah so it
feels natural i will be defending krista
stefano and that's that's fine because i
i i i'm i'm i you know i'm friends with
both men uh but i probably
have spent more time with derosa yeah
and me and me and de rosimi and derose
have become you know pretty good friends
and uh i think i mentioned it last time
where it's like i have the only
relationship that you seem to be able to
have with jonah rosa
which is just abusing and getting abused
and it's never and it's like that's not
me like i'm not like i'm not the guy
that's like
wants to i know you know what i'm on the
show and all that but like my my
personal life like i don't just
relentlessly harass my friends the whole
time he's he starts that also no you're
defending derozan i know yeah no no
i know it's gonna be tough because i
love that pimp pulled up both websites
this is gonna be great yeah so so so i
just wanted to play for you two things
just just just to let everybody know
what i'm dealing with over here it's so
funny okay okay yeah i came strapped
so derosa last time when i when i came
into philadelphia and he sent me this
these are these uh this is 27 seconds
all right of of a personal message from
jonah i love it i love it last time
babes thanks for saving the day on taste
buds today i really appreciate it buddy
last week was a
cyclone [ __ ] storm uh a million plates
spinning trying to keep them all going
uh so i really appreciate you stepping
in brother and it's a very i watched the
clip just now it's a very pleasant
energy you bring to the table
much different from my uh fists and
elbows approach
uh all right buddy love you pal
i mean
i mean
uh sincerely we're gonna all right yeah
that i get messages like that all the
time
so
you know i don't know if you guys know
but he has a big heart he's very
considerate friend i i do know that he's
he's thoughtful it was a sweet message
yeah it was nice to get yeah uh and then
i guess you told him that i was feeling
him from today okay so he sends he said
that's another thing
you know you guys send those voice
messages
and it really puts you on the back foot
with me because i just don't listen to
him until two days later i know because
i'm always like in the middle of a
conversation or you know what i mean
yeah i get it completely and it takes
with some people it doesn't take with
all this yeah okay but okay so now
we did a voice we're just talking about
this me and pimp because
we i left a voicemail
to voice text to save the film today and
it got lost in the show okay it's tough
it's tough it's like it's like another
podcast
it's a lot i i just it's just one of
those things that i can't grasp onto but
um but so now i guess he finds out that
i'm filling him from today and he sends
me this so this is turned this is what
this is where this is where you really
see my relationship with him on the on
display
hey buddy it's terosa just uh dropping
this message uh to you because i heard
you're filling in for me again on taste
buds today and um i just wanted to say
you're here
you might be able to fill my shoes on
that podcast
but you will never
oh
not on your table
not on any table
because i'm the king
you keep this message
so
this son of a [ __ ]
he i don't care i don't get competitive
like i'm not really an overly
competitive guy so like i always like
yeah whatever i don't care about you
know this that the other thing like i
won't really play really games because i
don't get into them board games i will
but like beer pong's never been my thing
ever so but if something happened this
summer where you guys started playing
beer pong yeah because we we rented a
house for a week for vacation we
probably talked about it and it got very
competitive we had the beer pong in the
pool thing someone bought a raft that
doubled as a beer pong in the pool to
blow up i love it and uh it took over i
mean i haven't really played beer pong
in a long long long long time actually i
have a question for you guys when did
you first encounter beer pong i don't
get where it came from college oh yeah
college did it come from the 90s was it
in the 80s oh it's definitely in the 90s
i don't know
when was beer pong invented let's check
that out i think i remember from college
like flip cup that type of thing which i
never really even did a lot either but
beer pong if you give it a chance it's
fun it's social yeah you get competitive
the first time i played it i was in
philadelphia at a at a frat party and
um really and i thought it was
disgusting because they didn't give a
[ __ ] i was the same age i was 20 21
whatever it was and uh the the like the
ball would bounce on the floor and they
wouldn't care they just throw it in the
drink and go yeah and even back then i
was like i can't do that so i never got
into beer pong yeah yeah yeah well
until this summer we ended up rekindling
beer pong this summer by by chance
because we were like it's a raft but
it's a beer and it got competitive
and i i think joe started in the 50s by
the way wow
there you go dartmouth college yeah
sounds about right dartmouth um
joe got super hyper competitive and he
loves to trash talk joe that's his big
thing he loves to trash talk even if you
didn't want to play another game or you
want to play a game you just want to
shut him
in
because he won't shut the [ __ ] up and he
won't and he also wins a lot
yeah and not he's not good
i got to make that i got to make that
clear it's just no one's good yeah all
right it kept going his way yeah
oh he was here right now if he's listen
when he listens to this or hears this
he's going to literally do that thing
like in the cartoons where steam comes
out of both ears
he sucks he's the worst winner in the
world because he is he he just beats the
[ __ ] out of you so even if you're like
like my friend rented a house had a pool
went up there i was floating around in
the pool sunny beautiful day and then
this guy just do you want to play no
then it's like you can't play that's why
you can't beat me son it's like you're
afraid to step up to the plate son
that's what's going on and it's just
it's just it's an hour of it before you
like this guy so at the end of the
summer you threw a party yeah so then
so we invited everyone from the house to
his house
so we went out and bought it the thing
the same play in his pool
and uh it just all it was all over again
kept going his way over and over and
then and then this is how close me and
derosa got over the past year like and
changed like he came to my house just to
hang out in the pool like me derosa
sometimes uh uh a couple of other people
but derosa was like a staple of my house
like five six times over the summer and
we played beer pong and he would beat me
every time and and every time he was the
he was the sorest winner in the world
man
again we are you are defending the rosa
all right here we go he he's he's
relentless you guys got to do the chance
what are we doing oh yeah we did oh yeah
before we we didn't really broach yeah
all right okay um yeah and the thing
that happened was derozan would play so
many games
that he would get bombed and then have
to stay over
oh my god it's true
what's a derosa sleepover like it's not
bad he's he's he's a good housewife
yeah he does he he goes to his room it's
his room now he knows where to get he
goes to his room like or likes like any
you just don't see him again he doesn't
wake up until like noon the next day
it's pretty exciting uh
and then he he drives a wrangler he
can't get out of my [ __ ] driveway so
yes he gives me the keys to his car so i
got to get his car out of the driveway
because he can't handle it again yes i'm
defending derosa
yeah uh
so jesus christ i was so happy to be
coming here until he sent me that
voicemail that's so funny dude
so cause he knows he's got me cause i'm
gonna come for you no matter what right
so it's just like to be upon he could
just kick me no but the thing i will
stress yeah he's not that like there
were games that he won that we were
playing for like a half hour because
nobody could win yeah and he just would
hit it and he lost a couple too no yeah
he lost a couple but he always ended up
on top over me
i can't stand it
so were you at the beach house with them
i was a beach house so now did did joe
ever make a fuss about no one going to
the beach with him because he had gripes
with cell
yeah oh no i didn't get roped into that
they were going like six in the morning
or something
joe
just wanted to go see whales jumping out
i'm like you guys that's right yeah you
want to go see whales what time is it
now it was 4 30. i'm like you guys want
to go to bed for an hour and a half get
up and go see the [ __ ] can you
imagine joe seeing whales at sunrise
it sounds too nice for him
another thing we did one time was we
were like oh let's all go for a bike
ride i don't know if you did the bike
running but we were like i did the
electric bike but i didn't go with you
guys okay we're like oh let's go for a
bike ride right so we have all these
bikes some people brought up bikes some
people some bikes were there from the
house like they're in the shed like you
could use them
so we all get on these bikes and we're
like oh we'll go for like an hour we'll
just drive to wherever maybe we'll drive
to like a
amount like a cliff up and look at the
ocean whatever
so we get out so everyone's dressed like
appropriately like shorts
um at leisure
you know athletic wear and joe is just
like he literally just came from like a
punk show he's got he's got on black
leather boots tight black jeans
and like a denim jacket it's a summer
and it's like his t-shirt and everything
and immediately i we all know it's the
wrong choice
like how do you not know it's a summer
day yeah and we're gonna go bike riding
for like an hour yeah anyway to make
matters worse
just by chance he got a bum bike
he got a rickety old bike with a chain
kept popping off and like this the
handleballs weren't tight and his seat
wasn't tight
and
where we were was a lot of this and
actually you know like and i was in an
electric yeah but like the people that
weren't on the electric bike really had
to work yeah so his chain kept popping
off and he kept going god damn it [ __ ]
god damn it he's like wait up wait up
and you have to get off the bike put on
the thing then get the chain back on
and um and then we're driving and like
you could just see it in his face man
but it was no turning back there was no
turning back we were on like a highway
yeah we were all in like a row right and
he was just like huffing it and he was
falling behind and he was just so
disappointed yeah and we're like why did
you dress like that
and then we finally get to a destination
we're driving for like a half hour
and
he is we were there i mean like a minute
later we see him coming down the
road the wheel i think is even doing
this like the wheel is so wobbly like
watching herbie come over the [ __ ]
thing with that wagon wheel on him
he gets there with this rickety bike
and he gets off the bike he kicks he
puts the kickstand on the bike falls
it's like the kickstand
and then he goes
i hope you don't mind
i'm just going to grab an uber
and he's like i'm not going to ride back
at that moment he wasn't able to enjoy
it
and then go back he had to get an suv
uber to put the bike in the back
and then he did not hang out he called
the uber put the uber in the back of the
suv and returned home yeah yeah that's
that's [ __ ] amazing that's him funny
he is funny like to like yeah he has a
way like when he it's like to me he's
very much like he's traits like me like
on the show we've learned this but i
suffer well yeah like we learned that
like there was like a a poll in the
beginning of the very beginning of the
show because i lost like the first five
episodes which hasn't happened again but
uh
and like they were like oh this might be
bad for the show
there's no variety you keep losing and
then it just was a resounding like they
polled people or something and it was a
resounding they they they just wanted me
to lose every [ __ ] it's just like see
them suffer
i guess when i suffer it's funny to
people yeah i really because it really
gets me and i think it gets him yeah
he he's got the same thing going um yeah
he did wear i mean i know i got we got
to get into
my thing on this i do have a
uh
uh stefano made my life harder okay at
one point so i do have okay something to
talk about there but um
but when you guys your atlantic city
show one thing that's a survival again i
i legitimately love deroza um but like i
was surprised he had on what he was
wearing
his pants were like ska
checkered yeah he had on like tweed or
twill pants yeah they were like they
were they have the giant squares on them
it looked like like you know something
dicky barrett would wear something like
that you know lead singer so i i never
saw him it was so flashy for him
yeah when he goes out yeah he puts on a
non-dungaree
well i get that
when he's going somewhere if he's not
wearing denim he's she's trying he's
trying to he's he's he's peacock he's
peacocking he has he has a he has a
bunch of slacks that are not denim that
he breaks out for special occasions this
is a 40-something-year-old man i know i
know i know i've really much resigned
myself to denim yeah denim denim and
athleisure yeah what's the point you i
mean you're not going to catch a pleat
on me until the day i die
you might not not a pleat oh no wait
there's pleats up here right this is
just a crease you might catch you with a
crease yeah if i'm wearing a suit i'll
have a i'll have a slack on but he'll
wear a slack
with a t-shirt you're bringing up a good
point against the rosa the fans have
they hate his jort collection
the fans have had enough of his jewelry
see i think that's a plus
no no no no no i applaud his his slacks
the slacks i like it i think it's uh i
think it's uh you know show an effort
yeah hi ladies and gentlemen this is joe
derosa coming to you from the taste buds
podcast i have my
night
grooves slow gems
overnight radio sexy voice going right
now because
i am losing my voice and this is the
only register i can speak in but it is
such a calm register it is such a calm
soothing voice
to deliver to you
some kind words
from the calm and soothing good people
at peloton
who are offering you currently two
months for free
let's talk about how
keeping things fresh in your life is the
best way to stay motivated and to keep
from burning out and doing the same
thing over and over it's a new year it's
a new you
you want to keep things
new
the peloton and the peloton bike plus
are ringing in the new year with so much
new new classes new music new ways to
keep your workouts fun and motivating
some of the new offerings that peloton
is adding to their lineup
uh let's talk about boxing peloton is
stepping into the ring with its newest
discipline no gloves needed
discover a fast furious and fun workout
with peloton instructors in your corner
uh there's a new artist series
coming up with new music selections
peloton is adding fun new artist series
classes so you can work out to the music
of a single artist for an entire class i
love that that's very cool from your
favorite hits to the deepest cuts
whatever it is you like
they got what you need
and there's more of a daily workout
variety it's easier to stick to your
goals as i said when you keep things
changing when you keep things
interesting peloton is a workout for
every goal every day every move
de-stress from a long day with 30
minutes of strength and 20 minutes of
cardio or just do a quick 15 total body
class workout you know before you before
you go to work
before you go outside before you for
whatever you do you just do it before
so here's what i want you to do
i want you for a limited time
for a limited time this offer lasts so i
want you to do it quick you got to try
the peloton app for free for two months
as i said two months free and it's going
to be 12.99 each additional month
new members only visit one
onepeleton.com
app to learn more that's two months free
and 12.99 each additional month at
o-n-e-p-e-l-o-t-o-n.com
all for expires january 31st 2022 terms
apply
folks
i speak to you
with this
very quiet voice because i'm a little
under the weather
physically that is mentally i'm actually
doing pretty well why
because there are people out there like
the good folks that better help helping
us stay in the right mental state this
podcast is sponsored
by better help
if there's something interfering with
your happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals for instance
this voice could get in the way of me
right now
why you say joe it's a bit you're losing
your voice who cares well this is how i
make my money this is my money maker
right here i do stand up on the stage
i sling sandwiches
and i charm people
this is how i make my money
and when something like this goes out a
tool like this i need it's easy to fall
into a funk but you know what
i'm not because better help is there to
assess the needs
of my own of anybody whatever your needs
are whoever you are and then match you
with your own licensed professional
therapist
you can start communicating in under 48
hours it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help
it's professional counseling done
securely online
there is a broad range of expertise
available which you know might not be
locally available in the area you live
in who knows
so check out betterhelp all right
they're here to do what to help
obviously and again keeping that right
mind state when the little things start
to get to you when the big things start
to get you
visit betterhelp.com taste buds that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
dot com slash taste buds and join the
over one million people who have taken
charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional special offer for taste
buds listeners right here get 10 off
your first month
at betterhelp.com
taste buds
what's up buds and babes and all the no
press fam joe derosa here if you're in
new york come out to the joey rose's bar
and sandwich shop
174 rivington we are open wednesday
through sunday we open at 12 p.m every
day and we go and serve until the
late late evening what else could you
ask for also i'm going to be on the road
if you want to see some stand up in 2022
i'm hitting buffalo in january at the
helium comedy club i'm hitting bananas
in rutherford new jersey
in february and i'm hitting the punch
line in philadelphia pennsylvania go to
jodarossainfo.com
for all information on ticket sales show
times blah blah blah blah blah blah all
that i love you guys i want to see you
out there
i was going to say i applaud applaud his
slacks i think it's showing effort and
and yeah but slacks are nice but the
slacks you were wearing were very showy
slides yeah but you know what it is like
like when someone like for me i wear
black a lot yeah and then what if i
throw on a pop of color people notice it
yeah it's like oh i don't normally i
don't register you with a green you know
shirt right it's like him with his denim
and his stuff when he pops on a slack
you say
he's elevating himself yeah i guess i i
was just like i was surprised at how how
flashy and and i say loud the pants were
for him it was funny but uh but you
applaud the jorts jord somewhere fans i
always give him a little bit of a one to
two for the george that's a guy that
that's look i i don't wear george myself
yeah but i applaud look for me like the
only one wearing george
yeah i don't wear them you know who
wears them is john cena and like i don't
know i don't have a scene of jorts i
mean cena has i think everybody's all
jordan's jordan's off iraq like yeah
like cena has like like actual son
george so meant to be jorts yeah my two
jorts are old jeans that i cut that look
like you know like you wear them in the
80s or the 70s like they're that kind of
yeah but that kind of jort you know well
how short are they no they're like right
right a little above the knee that's
where a scene is huh
no no but cena's are like
like
cena's are like a dark blue like with
white stitching when he puts a like a
belt through it and tucks in yeah like
they're like they're like the jort of
like a dad
okay were you you have hip jorts i
i believe so all right my drawer would
be like what a rock and roll singer
would wear
okay am i getting this drink
[Music]
[Laughter]
my jordan would be like one like uh what
is
okay so
it's a little bit more like uh
organic yeah as opposed to off the rack
guys and i really hope and if john cena
if you're listening and we know that you
are i mean nothing i mean nothing by it
i mean you know that cena like really
i don't know what we're talking about
now but like see but cena really won me
over in recent years man like uh he's oh
i love cena
i don't know for a few years there i was
like
yeah well that's a great thing he's
polarized yeah you know let's go through
you know sucks but the more that people
didn't like cena the more i liked it
same so it started going like that and
now
i would rather see him
than like like if there's a rock movie
and a cena movie
like i'm going to go see the cena movie
it's not even close and i love the rock
yeah no the rock though is like he's
surpassed
he's like just transcended now he's an
archetype yeah he's the rock right in
every movie is like really funny comedic
yeah he is really funny like nuanced
shot in the comedic chops yeah so wait
so who is the roses george like are they
like you're cool george or they like his
no actually you know
what's funny they are like my jorts yeah
but he's so lanky
he's still like
he's so lanky and he's got he's got long
stems yeah
and
you know pimp shoots in 4k
you know we got a
fisheye lens on joe does a really dainty
cross of his legs
the attention gets called okay all right
so yeah there they are
this picture this is when they filled in
for me
and this is chris and joe's episode in
joe's house on the red leather couch not
for nothing chris is also wearing a dad
cotton docker shirt
none of us are as cool as we think are
not a single one of us go back to that
picture of chris i mean he looks like a
dad right there so he's a ticket he is a
milky white oh that that leads me to my
story about him okay him being a dad
okay um
wait wait if we're getting into this
let's just do a okay it's a b-a-t-t-l-e
b-a-t-t-l-e oh no it's t-e-a-t-a-s-t-e
but
okay okay so that's how we started off
right it's time for
t-a-s-t-e
and then we had to do this i'll always
lo i still love you no matter what
happens what happens
come here come here
what happens i love you no matter what
happens i love you no matter what
happens i love you it actually works in
a way yeah it doesn't work something to
something clicks in your brain where
you're like oh i love this person i'm
aware okay so you can try that at home
in anything like over over the christmas
yeah like over christmas holidays when
you're with your family when shit's
going down at the table and you're
talking politics just grab on to them
and shake your grip grandmother and tell
him can i make a suggestion yeah
mistletoe
if it's not appropriate for you to kiss
someone like you wouldn't i mean i
wouldn't kiss my brother right right but
if i said in the mistletoe i i and that
was the new rule
i think that's what people should take
yeah yeah you could do that that could
be a as a matter of fact
send us tag us
at taste buds mistletoe
on on twitter and or whatever and send
us the video of you guys doing the chant
on the e mistletoes yeah we'll post them
we'll retweet them is mistletoe still
legal is that a thing i know
mistletoe feels like it should have been
me too no
i don't know i mean who's giving the
permission the plant
no but the berry it's more of it it's
not a permission it's more of an
invitation yeah oh yeah both yeah are
both participants willing or you get
kissed sometimes and you're like what
the hell are you like oh
i think you gotta only deal with willing
participants right yeah yeah i wouldn't
suggest but let me ask you this yeah who
invented mistletoe what were their uh
what were their intentions i don't know
but i know someone i could look it up
you know who i always loved in my life
always loved is the guy with a mistletoe
belt buckle i love that guy that's the
guy that wears a t-shirt that says the
man the legend yeah yeah yeah yeah that
that's the guy i i look small doses
small doses but i [ __ ] i love that
guy i love like seeing like a like like
a older uncle like trying to be funny
with it yeah i i i you can't help but
buy in yeah yeah that's exactly not the
guy that who's a douche who's like no no
but the uncle who's just like oh i'm
making a dad joke the hell yeah i love
it i have a hard time not appreciating
dad humor i do i do because it's so
freaking corny that it it's it's i'm
laughing at how corny it is but still
love it yeah yeah
here we go england
you want to redial read it
the tradition of kissing under the
mistletoe seems to have started among
servants in england before gaining
popularity with the middle classes as
part of this tradition men were allowed
to steal a kiss oh there you go from any
woman caught under the mistletoe
refusing was considered bad luck well
there you go we hit the nail on the head
there yeah that started in a very what
what era was that seems to start amongst
servants in england i don't know
when was it
when was it invented
when did it start there it is oh this
one's saying asian greece ancient greece
whoa uh during the roman era uh so there
you go started with the roman ender i
started with the roman era ended with
the me too error missile okay that's
mistletoe's full yeah full story i think
you i think mistletoe still has a place
i wonder if you could claim mistletoe as
a defense i think you could there's a
missile i think in new york staying like
cynical i just mean with a peck on the
cheek you know
that'd be funny if like like people are
just going after someone and they just
like it was [ __ ] missiles though
the when what party was it that i was
here with with it was before the
pandemic right with the stefano where he
was here with his his daughter was it
halloween no
i think it might have been super bowl
yeah yeah for sure okay yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so this is my story
and this is nothing you know we just
it's time for
b-a-t-t-l-e buds now you can go okay all
right
now again i i like to stefano yes
nothing against him and and his daughter
was delightful yeah like i mean that
like we had a blast what's going on
delilah delilah delilah was
so much fun to hang out with but for the
um
so for for
i remember the super bowl party i
remember this i brought a date now i
don't often bring dates places
um you know because it's just like what
am i gonna do
bring people places um it was a safe
space this safe space friends we were
here with friends you know what i mean i
was still like trying to impress her at
that point um so i brought it to the
party you know super bowl parties
introduced around they were they were
famous people here you know what i mean
you know
it was a thing
and december was here with delilah and
uh she was great she was entertaining us
she's on live cracker firecracker and
chris is very charming in fact that's
another thing like you know i hadn't
been seeing this girl very long and uh
you know chris is very strapping
handsome
man again you're defending the rosa
against chris
well but i i believe that guys that the
men in the audience are all going to
turn on this definitely with this okay
okay okay i love it that's what i think
and and
uh so i brought this girl around and uh
you know you know right away you bring
in here chris chris very charming
because very handsome very tall you know
so right away you're a little bit like
you know he just got he was getting a
show on true tv so there goes my
advantage you know what i mean it was
like it was all this [ __ ] and uh
you know delilah's so much fun so my
date was down there playing with her and
uh they were playing for like a half
hour and they would sound like you heard
laughter and everything and then it just
got quiet
and
my date comes down the stairs
she looks dejected
and i go
what happened baby what's going on and
she goes uh
well delilah said uh we were laughing at
a joke and she stopped laughing and goes
when you laugh
you look like a clown
you look like a scary clown and you're
terrifying me
she [ __ ] meant it
she meant it
now this girl pimp
she was beautiful like there was no
scary clown vibes coming off this girl
you know what i mean like because there
was also the dance too i was bringing a
girl to the party you know i was gonna
bring a scared looking clown to the barn
and oh my god oh my god and kids [ __ ]
but kids are because kids aren't there
there's no filter that they're not
talking
oh my god that's so because yeah like
like like she believes that she the rest
of the night was spent with her i caught
her looking into like reflections
like going into mirrors and like like my
night went from one from having a great
super bowl party to like trying to
convince this girl forget about getting
laid like no i was just trying to
convince her not to throw herself off
the balcony i'm like you don't look like
a scarecrow but the truth is that
children say [ __ ] and they meet it i
know she's not lying she doesn't say
that for a fact she in that moment
that's deep
that's real cuts deep right okay because
i've never been really insulted by a
child i haven't i've ever heard about it
because my niece
so one time i was hanging out with my
niece madison and at the time she was
like six or something like that right
and uh we were we were playing uh
nintendo it was it not even live here
it's my old place and i was uh like
going in hard on it i wasn't giving her
any leeway i was dominating and i was
i was giving her a little taste of the
derozan
and i saw her um getting annoyed i saw
it start
and uh that only made me want to do it
more because there was really nothing
she could do you know like i think we
were playing like i think we were
playing uh
um uh nba jam oh you were outside i was
on fire yeah and uh or maybe that or it
was like i don't know maybe it was
street fighter it was something where i
was like hadoop it was i don't know i
think you had 30 years of experience
yeah
and i was like what's the matter huh you
know whatever and then she gets up at
one point she just i saw the steam
she's six six eight right she gets up
and she throws the remote oh she goes
you know what uncle sal
you're boring
[Laughter]
and then she like
i started laughing so hard because i was
like she had to that was what she
thought was going to
get me back yeah like she she did
nothing she could do game wise
and so she's like i have to i had to get
him back and she was looking for a mic
drop and her mic dropped i'd say she
found it
and i left i just kept laughing so hard
i'm like i'm boring like it's such a
funny thing to say to someone and then
like later that night
when i was trying to go to sleep
i was like why would she say that
like
where did she even get that like
why would she say that about me because
i'm not boring
like if you ask people about me they
would not describe me as boring so where
did she get off
so the next time when she came back
my whole bit really but it's true the
next time she came back to my house
i said can i talk to you in the other
room
we had the family over i said can i talk
to you in the other room for a second
so she came in the other room i was like
last week
and i said you got really mad
and he said that was boring
and she goes yeah because this is the
deal right
she's not perceptive enough to lie to
hurt my feelings yeah she was too young
for that
so she she called up the first thing
that came with her which means it was
true this fact is going to upset my life
which means it really did hurt my
feelings ultimately so she really did
get me
you know yeah and i remember i was like
you remember you said i was boring last
week and she's like yeah i'm like
why would you say that i was boring like
i'm not boring you know that i was like
you come here like we play video games
we eat
cookies we go to the movies like
and she's like why does that make you
not boring oh i know wow i know well how
do you even answer that i was like
touche [ __ ] you know like i didn't know
what to do
so even in the midst of all those fun
things like you're a lame partner to be
yeah you know she was still digging
in but but but but still it sounds like
years ago how has she aged into enjoying
you she's she has that same attitude
she's 14 now
and she's still got a like a like a mean
little better attitude it's not going to
get better
one more niece who don't give a [ __ ]
wow she's loving and i love her and she
loves me but like she's like she she's
the niece who like sometimes can't be
bothered yeah yeah especially at 14
right yeah yeah um all right so derosa
right so uh to stefano so so so brought
the date around
big handsome funny guy successful funny
guy uh he's sort of cuts her
self-confidence down to nothing and then
we were all laughing about it too yeah
which was it was
funny it's so funny though that she said
that and she was trying to
my date was trying to to
to laugh a lot but i already knew this
was a lost cause i already know she
couldn't hold in the laughter yeah
because like it's so funny because i
also know delilah well it's so funny
that she just squared up with her after
like half hour of play time and said you
look like a scary clown yeah and you're
terrifying me yeah and they're
terrifying me and then and then and then
she oh no no no you're scared no no and
i'm gonna have dreams that was it
oh that's it you look yeah and and and
tonight it wasn't and you're terrifying
me and tonight i'm gonna have nightmares
about you yes is what she [ __ ] said
it was nuts
so okay so this is how it gets worse for
me okay
because of once again to stefano so
we're all laughing and i'm like we have
to tell him but not no we don't want to
get her in trouble like it's literally
like the [ __ ] funniest if i wasn't
trying to get late it would have been
the funniest thing in the world and uh
and like she so we tell stefano and he
crumbles and he pulls my date aside and
starts telling her no you don't stand
she's just like that she says so i'm
looking over in the corner and the two
of them and she starts laughing and i'm
like he's making her feel better
he's just son of a [ __ ] i couldn't do
it yeah i tried to make it so and then i
started thinking i'm like is this a scam
these two run yeah am i getting hustled
right now
so i you know i don't know if you could
trust i don't know if you could trust
i don't know if you trust this stuff at
all hold on hold on hold on
did he train delilah to do that yeah did
he pimp his pulled up okay uh
an article that says there are certain
qualities that must be shared in order
to form the bonds of a good and true
friendship okay okay let's go through
them sure number one they're kind i have
a i have a lot of friendships that
aren't involved with kindness a lot of
the files guys haven't said a kind word
what i'm saying
with a filter of derozan stefano oh oh
okay okay i will say derosa can be kind
but derosa can also be unkind
he can my
my my initial thing of kindness with
derosa i would say he's a good guy
i don't know if i'd say he's the kindest
guy the thing about derosa is
de rosa is his himself unapologetically
and if you just meet him he's still
himself and if he's gonna give his best
friend [ __ ] he'll give someone he just
meant [ __ ] yeah and so i love that about
him because he's very forward he doesn't
put on airs he doesn't have a bad
personality no but he can be unkind he
can be unkind
what sour patch that's the rosa he's a
sour patch kid
yeah
rosa was a candy yeah yeah yeah i mean
jorts yes well then then
then stefano was a skittle
taste the rainbow
they're honest okay i'd say they're
honest i'd say derose is honest yeah uh
chrissy d
no chris is honest i'm just starting to
think of like what people's what he
might say or curtis i don't know well i
don't know like i'm saying there was
some weird underhanded [ __ ] going on
around here with my date it sounded like
a hustle
okay okay i'm just saying we can't rule
it out and so when everybody's at home
thinking about this argument you know
we want proof chris is honest i'm just
trying to play both sides of the coin
they're individual they're individual
sure
they're individual yeah they're indeed
there's no one like them
well that's true of both of those guys
they're honest they're the video okay
they're adventure they're adventurous
well
i gotta tell you yeah i don't know if i
i don't know if i'd say it derose is
adventurous i
is just stefano adventurous
it'll do anything you put in front of
him yeah really
i think i think he's probably too
adventurous
i don't think that might be a strike
against chris yeah he's very adventurous
i've never seen
chris do half the things i've seen
duress to do okay okay i think chris is
adventurous but then sometimes when
chris gets has a little too many pinot
grigios yeah
he's he's too adventurous oh okay all
right i think he said that about himself
of course he'd go lights out i mean
say what you will about derosa he showed
up to your biking expedition dressed
incorrectly and still did it
but he
after we went for the hiking portion he
just ubered back home well it was a
miserable experience yeah
yeah took the rest i had to convince
derosa to come to halloween
yeah had to convince him but he was
there
yeah yeah yeah i will say
de rosa takes a little bit of persuading
sometimes yeah
to commit to an adventurous idea and i'm
not going to call him outright
unadventurous and he also uses your
adventures you make him go on against
you when he's angry yeah yeah yeah but
all these things that will come on the
adventure arms folded until he's won
over yeah which is not the right energy
or is it
because why else would you keep inviting
them if you didn't love that energy
that's a good question brian
that's a good question who do you hang
out with socially more i guess
socially more pop
i hang out with them probably rosa
socially more but it's only because you
know chris has a family and stuff yeah
but but i hang out with chris a lot too
sure but chris doesn't have a sandwich
shop
you're not in business with chris that
is that is a big adventure you're right
you're right i mean look like in terms
of like boys you want to hang out with
do you want to do you want to do the
suburban dad hang or do you want to do
the [ __ ] deroses drinking his third
bottle of [ __ ] jamison we don't know
where he's going with this yeah de rosa
you get with him and he'll be drinking
on any day yeah chris doesn't drink
unless he's doing drinking okay and then
drinking it
just goes yeah yeah all right oh oh god
okay all right hold on hold on hold on
here we go so pimp is is this from his
website or we're on both wikipedia pages
okay pampers pulled up their websites
and their wikipedias and now we will
give some facts about each okay
on twitter rose's wikipedia there is a
section called musical projects
something we don't know anything about i
don't know anything about derosa and
childhood friend james pink stone
that sounds fake
formed a comedic sex rap group called
deep
after releasing why are you saying it
like that
i'm just processing it you were doing
videos where you were playing jelly roll
that's true i know it's a sex thing
through me but now i get it it's it's
it's it's all comedic with it with a
sexual slant and i don't like the way
you're setting this up you're mocking it
as you read it
when i when i wrote when i don't know
something i just i was processing it at
one time i get it i get it i didn't know
this i knew he used to maybe have a
hip-hop group i didn't know it was
comedically sex
called deep is hysterical right after
releasing their debut album the game
plan in 2005 and performing several live
shows oh dear lord can we get the
footage howdy folks
love talking to you and love talking to
you about hellofresh
you get farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal recipes
delivered right to your doorstep skip
the trips to the grocery store and count
on hellofresh to make home cooking easy
fun and affordable that's why it's
america's number one meal kit you may
hear my sultry sound today and it's
because i'm a little under the weather
and i love hello fresh when i'm feeling
great but when you're under the weather
oh my god it's even better
this is just an amazing service we've
talked to you about it before i'm going
to talk to you about it again the new
year is a great time to focus on what's
most important to you for me
it's it's saving money
okay
how do you save money you order less
takeout
you cook for yourself
you prioritize your wellness hellofresh
is here to help with the endless options
to make cooking at home simple and
enjoyable
my time is important
you you don't want to waste time you get
home you forgot a thing you need one
ingredient whatever
that can ruin a whole meal it could be a
whole night quite frankly
hellofresh cuts back on time spent in
the kitchens you can spend it on other
resolutions for the new year
with meals ready in around 30 minutes or
less
quick and easy meals including 20 minute
recipes are also included and low prep
and easy clean up options provide an
even faster route to putting food on the
table
i have used hellofresh i use hellofresh
and i am somebody who likes to cook i do
enjoy going to the store
and buying
things to plan a big meal whatever
i'm not saying i don't enjoy that but
very
infrequently do we have time to do all
that
you don't want you don't want the
ingredients sitting in your fridge for a
week two weeks things go bad you toss
stuff you waste money
you throw away food which i think is is
a crime to do
uh and and this service is here to help
you not have to do that
so
even if you're just supplementing your
dietary
uh uh practice with hellofresh it's an
amazing thing or if you're going full
fledge hello fresh you ain't gonna go
wrong there either you got me trust me
go to hellofresh.com tastemud16
and use code tastebud16
for up to 16 free meals and three gifts
that's like 19 things
go to hellofresh.com
buds 16
and use taste and use the code
tastebud16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts
america's number one meal kit hellofresh
folks our next partner has the product
that i have been using every day
since the start of the new year started
taking these athletic greens
that's the name of the company athletic
greens why did i start taking them
because as we've said on the show and in
other ads actually on the show
time is precious time is short
you want to be healthier you want to
stay healthier you want to continue to
improve yourself
and athletic greens has made that very
easy for me and it has been a great
assister in making that road a bit
easier for me so what is the stuff you
ask
well with one delicious scoop of
athletic greens
right out of the right out of the
container into your glass you're
absorbing 75 high quality vitamins
minerals whole whole food source super
foods probiotic
probiotics and
with one delicious scoop of athletic
greens you're absorbing 75 high quality
vitamins minerals whole food source
superfoods pry
probiotics
i always want to call them probiotics
for some reason probiotics and
adaptogens to help you start your day
right
it's a special blend of ingredients
supports your gut health which i love
because
i'm somebody i get bloated i get
i've i've have it on my gut over the
years so i appreciate some gut health i
really do this helps your nervous system
we all know i need that you've been
listening to the episode today
you hear what these people are saying
about me
you hear how calm i am right now why
i'll tell you why
athletic greens
it's helping your immune system it helps
your energy
your recovery your focus
aging
all these things
i personally consume it because i like
help in these areas and again it's one
scoop into the drink and that's it
you're done you're out the door you can
bring it with you when you travel
it's a great gift to give to friends and
family because we all like to share
health advice with friends and family
right when we discover something but
often
it's not the easiest thing if you say to
somebody hey i found a great gym
but they live in kentucky and you don't
well that gym's not gonna do them much
good but this is something you can
actually share with everyone you know
i'm telling you folks very very good let
me show you a few health facts at you
it's lifestyle friendly whether you keto
paleo
vegan dairy free gluten free doesn't
matter
this works with all of them
it contains less than one gram of sugar
no gmos no nasty chemicals or artificial
anything while still tasting good it
costs you less than three dollars a day
you're interested in your health and
it's cheaper than your cold brew habit
that's also cheaper by the way usually
than buying a lot of uh your daily uh
supplements and vitamins
uh athletic greens has over seven
thousand five star reviews it's
recommended by professional athletes
and trusted by leading health experts
such as tim
ferriss and michael gervais
right now it's time to reclaim your
health
and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition especially
heading into the fluid cold season just
one scoop and a cup of water every day
that's it that's it
no need for a million different pills
and supplements to look out for your
health and to make it easy athletic
greens is going to give you a free
one-year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs
with your first
purchase it's a heck of a deal all you
have to do is visit athleticgreens.com
taste buds
again that is athleticgreens.com
taste buds to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional
insurance
right
he must have footage he must have
searching youtube yeah wow yeah the duo
felt that people were taking the act too
seriously
that's so funny if you come out on stage
as a comedic sex act and people take it
as a serious rap sex there's one born
every minute man oh that is so funny
that people because in one way you laugh
and the other way it's our horror yeah
you're like we're doing this [ __ ] to
make fun of yes yeah yeah um
not understanding that they were extr
and not understanding that their extreme
misogyny yeah was a parody of existing
sex right now to me
that is that is such a a strike on
deroza's side because a full decade and
a half before the world got concerned
about how women are getting treated in
entertainment derose has stepped away
from a a successful project because he
thought he was not adding the right side
to the conversation all right that's
[ __ ] that's a stand-up guy bro
he's under fire and he bailed no no no
wait if you could scroll up one more
time who's calling him on the fire back
then nobody well hold on because there
are citations which you need in
wikipedia and what i want to know is
who cared enough
about they had three or four life
performances in 2005 16 years ago who
went in and put the reasoning why this
did derosa make this entry
uh oh that's a good question
i don't know i guess you could make your
own entry derosa was on board to death i
didn't know that
was he on board to death i don't know
let's see what he played in so much oh
he was
bob i gotta ask you about that
i love that show um all right so
wait let's scroll i just want to read
the rest of that article about derosa
because it says he formed another one
as a result the friends disbanded deep
in 2007 deroza and his friend paul chell
released an album titled
two in the one in the
under the name salsa windfall
in 2009 derosa and pinkstone reunited
like who's reporting who's reporting
this yeah uh reunited as an electro pop
act named funeral in the mirror electro
pop i feel like pink stone i think pink
stone wrote this named funeral to
release an album titled old wolf
thoughts in 2012 derosa teamed up with
fellow comedians bob place ben evans and
michael albanese and james mcdaniel for
a comedy rap video reminiscent of deep
titled grab.dalla
which was released through laughing
skull studios youtube channel in january
2016 derozan released a five-song
digital ep under the name demon riot
through a bandcamp website and a second
ep titled deformed disco which was made
available a month later de rosa has also
composed and recorded the theme songs
for his own four podcasts
i mean i had no idea i mean this is 45
years ago he was in a thing called
grab.doll
can we find any of this i just found a
youtube channel called salsa windfall a
joe deriza a joe de rosa side project
uh you've had a huawei yeah
youtube is there a song there's a whole
youtube let me know oh all right let's
play the songs all right is this going
to go for against derozan i think the
fact that we've spent this whole show
talking about
means derosa wins
i do he's just he's he's a more
interesting guy to talk about the whole
thing has been based around
yeah but you need people in your life
exactly as we've described
the fact that he did salsa windfall so
it's i think it's a strike against my
i think it's a plus for you yeah i think
so
let's listen to it
[Music]
this is swinging back in my direction
ice
i don't i don't i don't well you should
you should be asking him to cut this i
don't know yeah just yeah you should ask
him to cut that that swung
that's i mean the pendulum swung back
the guy's trying he's out there trying
man like come on you think every episode
of ij's a [ __ ] winner no i do not
right you can't be judged by your miss
you know your creative misc
this is pretty good
[Music]
this sounds like i get paid for loving
on the swing of soundtrack it sounds
like fly to the concords
that's pretty good come on now let's see
where it goes
like
he made this uh he joe wrote this this
is pretty funky
i don't know
[Music]
copyright 2007 joda rosa
48 views i didn't realize he had such a
he had oh come on man that don't matter
i know it doesn't i thought it would be
funny though that's it's gonna watch
this and want to commit and want to just
jump off a ledge no i don't want that
from you joe we're just poking fun here
honestly i wish i could make music
hulk
if we were younger men
if this was us in our 20s yeah i would
try to make a bet with you right now 100
bucks whoever can make love to a woman
to this song first
and it would be the grand adventure of
the summer oh that's so funny it would
be great because
because
it really is a specific thing
you can't yeah it would be a fun it
would be well it's called what's in the
same of this band called uh salsa
windfall
okay fair devil of the mysteries so
listeners
send us a video of you having sex in
this song
just send it to our what is it taste
buds email
just tweet it at us well you can't right
you can on twitter no you can on twitter
uh don't do that i would i would also
send it to our email and just title it
uh taste buds salsa windfall there you
go
all right all right let's let's let's
let's let's fair play let's pull
something with chris yeah
i i feel like and i know chris is very
funny very very nice very interesting
man but he's not getting a lot of play
in this episode i feel like that goes
against him all right i'll tell you
something i'll tell you something about
chris yeah he he's chris the stefano
he's italian he took a 23 in me he was
98 german
he found that out he found that out
about a year ago he literally rewrite
his whole existence 35 years as an
italian even his stage persona's italian
thing he was like no he's like 99 german
and then he's like it makes sense look
at my face
look at it looks like the master race is
crazy
i don't know what this is but oh him on
tmz
uh cause curious on a show called guy
code yeah and it was all about i think
that kind of topic have you had that
experience the tmz guys at lax yeah i've
i had tmz a couple times but i just
don't say anything it's happened really
wow it's happened to me twice and if if
it's an innocuous question i might have
answered i find those tmz guys to be so
friendly and nice like well they want to
elicit a response from me no no no but
like even the all i've gotten is
softball questions
yeah they're like so how's this la
weather and i'm like it's actually
pretty nice
like like because i recognize that you
picture you after that the report on tv
brian quinn thinks la weather is mild
he he had that look in that clip of the
guy i remember that feeling when they
come up with you because the camera's
got tv off guard yeah so so there's a
thing of like what are they about to
[ __ ] ask
how do i navigate this minefield and and
i remember the first time it happened to
me at the ella it's always lax i had
that feeling of like oh [ __ ] like i
don't want to say anything right right
but then the guy was so nice that the
next time i was like hey
what's going on and the guy walked with
me to my car but like only asked like
[ __ ] cool questions i was like these
guys are great yeah i don't know if
that's the way it goes all the time no i
i guess not but uh yeah
here on this wikipedia somebody updated
it christopher de stefano who is
predominantly german
oh that's funny great what a funny story
uh
oh god yeah i don't know where we netted
out on this i don't well all right i
would say that
where are we at pimpy where are we at
are we
i was just about to get into more about
because i could go on and on about
derosa for sure but like but i was also
going to get like all right we're we're
at the end of it
our final sponsor on the taste buds
program today is me
joe derosa
taking up some valuable ad time to bring
you a very valuable message
which is
christos stefano
is a pig
i'd like to thank you
for sitting in my chair
all these weeks
and giving such strong stern
valid arguments about my character my
demeanor my person
my worth
christos stefano though
is a pig
all right let's let's not we we got
another another one to do
let's let's just lean into the fact that
it's going to be a lot of fun hopefully
for the listeners
yeah come on i love you both you're both
great yeah uh i couldn't joe i couldn't
um
couldn't defend you because the nature
of the show is i'm gonna go against you
so when you inevitably leave me a
message or call me about this episode
and you and you log all of your
complaints
take it with a grain
i don't think anything really came out
other than the salsa windfall
i don't know if that's going to be your
undoing imagine salsa windfalls is
undoing now
i mean if you don't think that we should
be making salsa windfall merch now salsa
windfall
all right can he reform that with us can
we reform salsa oh we gotta reform it
just to stop us sound off in the
comments if you want if you think this
should be salsa windfall merch and would
you wear it
what here's what i think has to happen
we need to steep ourselves in salsa
windfall a little further so the next
couple of shows i will bring it up and i
will give him [ __ ] for it you guys sound
off on it we'll see if it if it takes
can we start a hey babe episode with one
you two singing his song oh yeah that's
great that's great oh is it on spotify i
gotta find this out this is i mean he
should be defending salsa in something
has he he
has he defended saul dude if the three
of us form reform salsa win windfall
yeah and like you guys go out you do you
guys do shows yeah we do like an opening
like a five-minute opening
trio yeah why not
what does that mean like he just like he
all of a sudden he came into a lot of
salsa salsa like a win for financial
wouldn't yeah you're right like what
does that mean like all of a sudden he
has copious amounts of
salsa
you remember when chili's used to give
you free salsa and chips they don't no
it's 4.99 now you're [ __ ] me oh it's
disgusting it's like getting bread dude
i wanted to eat chilies for the first
time in years and i was so excited about
that that's the whole thing you go there
for they they break you over peace in
the beginning no salsa went full the
opposite of a salsa windfall you got to
pay for it why they're tightening the
boot the titan and the person 99. that's
absurd
who's this actually chili's
it's bottomless chili's if you're
watching
and we know that you are what did you do
what did you do is everybody doing that
i don't know bottomless
it's bottomless but it's always
yeah we should go there with like 15
people oh and just order one order and
just just run them out now i have an
idea just for this episode why don't we
call derosa for the reveal
oh my [ __ ] king okay all right does
he know we did this does not no this is
phenomenal
i think our our viewers listeners
hey bud we're doing the pod you have a
moment
yeah are you gonna bring me on yeah i i
mean you're on you're on speaker right
now unless you want me to just you know
oh no i'm i'm i'm here yeah i'm at my
apartment
okay you have you have a moment
i got a moment you know i saw that you
were listening to music you love the
music right
yeah i got i got some some family here
for christmas okay okay
they are afraid to see me
q says hello
to iq will you um
what were you listening to we listened
to uh
we got some christmas tunes oh cool cool
anything anything
anything
we listen to anything by uh salsa
windfall or
yeah yeah a band called salsa windfall
what do you what of it
[Laughter]
were you spinning what of it
were you spitting salsa windfall or deep
what are you
spinning no not deep or so swift what
are you guys doing what are you trying
to do right all right here's what we did
today
here's what we did the game is this the
first step we the first that we recorded
today
uh q had a suggestion and we we we
molded over we thought it was a really
funny suggestion the battle today was
derosa versus stefano
did you do it please tell me you did it
we did it
we are at the humble pie segment we
wanted to loop you in
all right listen i'm gonna call right
now i'm gonna get creamed
[Laughter]
i you know joe
joey i had you i i was arguing for you
and i i honestly i think if anybody
listened to the episode first you would
win
so q you were my side i'm not surprised
by that
well we actually joe you you
the the derosa conversation is is was
and is so fruitful
that we we we neared the 45 minute mark
and we had only only talked about one
thing about chris
and and pimp's like look we gotta call
this now we're right at the end of the
episode it's almost like we didn't even
get to the stefano but but
to be fair there was a lot of pros
and and some cons you know it was what
it was oh yeah you're gonna get a few
cons yeah yeah yeah
when i was just i don't i can't remember
if i told you guys this i certainly have
to have a total of the pockets when we
were in ac doing that show
um when i was walking to meet you guys
at that bar
after the show yeah yeah this group of
girls
like they they go to rosa like from
across the the hall and i look up and i
go hi hi ladies and they all give me the
finger they go [ __ ] you no
yeah and i go what was that for and they
go that's for making fun of the stefano
and calling him a pig and i go well he's
a pig
they go they go so are you and i go
fair enough that i just walked away dude
that is you didn't tell me that
yeah dude it was it was a whirlwind oh
how funny is that by the way i was like
wasn't even there and it's not like his
show was that night and his fans were
there these are just like
lay people in the streets
yeah it was it was insane and then two
of the girls
dm'd me on instagram and apologized for
it and the one took her apology back i
guess because they didn't respond fast
enough she goes you know what on second
thought [ __ ]
we've heard all we need to know about
those people and might i add even though
this is the tail end of me defending
chris which i didn't even have to do yet
that doesn't those people don't speak
well to chris they're not representing
chris
yeah that's rude if this is the kind of
this is the kind of fan base he's
culling together
that's what he deserves
all right we're gonna we're gonna go to
the phones with you and it won't take
long we'll go to the phones and then
we'll then we'll do the humble pie
uh all right so we just okay
uh
by the way i just want to tell my
friends guys sorry they have me on the
podcast for a moment i'm sorry
yeah yeah yeah sorry sorry
all right go ahead guys chris is like
your gay best friend always full of fun
joe is like your grumpy grandpa you love
him but you can only be around him for a
short time
all right we're going to let's read a
bunch of these you could say you could
stay there
go up a little bit and then if if we got
to skip i'll skip uh if you want to read
any feel free yeah the one up the one
above that uh
uh
that's the one this person says if i saw
joe in public i think i'd immediately
start crying out of fear
go go up a little bit more
i think i like joe because he is the
same person as my dad
he will be anti-family christmas card
but if you let him know when and where
he needs to be and provide the outfit he
will be there
okay very true all right
uh
uh keeps keep scrolling it all depends
on my mood sometimes if i'm really
anxious chrissy is too much for me
though when i have though when i have a
headache joe yelling about mcdonald's is
too much as well
here's a positive one bud
uh joe should win because we've all just
given him the title of villain but he's
an angel love him
oh wow that's a nice one yeah he's a
good one well chris has tits
[Laughter]
but but joe serves me sandwiches quite a
pickle
so he likes chris cause
that's great that might be my favorite
so far
uh
chris gives me a headache and is why i
only watch the superior nope presh
program
meaning taste buds i guess when i first
heard derozan taste buds it made me want
to see more of his work and he became my
favorite comedian come on now whoa
oh this is a good one oh wow
i prefer a man that makes sandwiches
rather than daughters nice wow
baby you might have a little momentum
here oh scroll back up one it's like
choosing between the dark side of the
moon and the wall
i don't i this person says i don't even
know who chris is and i still pick him
over joe
that's the win that's amazing uh joe
calls that the win
that's amazing oh my god oh this is
funny
all right let's go to let's humble pie
let's go to it drum roll pimpy we get
the percentages
again only this so they did change the
polls they changed these polls many
people see polls less now okay we got 5
000 votes though so we got about 5 000.
uh
oh
i won't tell you who pimp chose
but i will tell you that uh
5 000 votes ish
i hope my silence indicates something
joe i i feel that when people listen to
this episode
that that those statistics are going to
change
i think we rerun this we re-run this i
will i want you to no i'm not going to
say joe i want you to guess the
percentages
82 to 18. be more kind to yourself
78 to uh 22.
okay
no no no no no no no no you're being too
mean
68.6
to 31.4 percent that's terrible
you know what you know what makes me
laugh even more it's like the um the
nature of polls that we put up on
twitter are solely from taste buds
so like
you know the the the the the the uh
they're busting his balls
you know the people
floating around the poles are usually
like that should notify it's a taste bud
pole
and you so you would think that they
might skew in his favor slightly
no no no i i think i think that would
work do nothing but work against me to
be honest with you yeah
people want to give you a zing
where's the fun in that but also too
maybe i'm just not liked you know who
knows
joe 31
still means that thousands of people
liked you
you know what sal go [ __ ] yourself
i was saying in a nice way
you see this is why you're at [ __ ] 31
i like it i wear that 31 like a badge
guess what cue
you'll never beat me
son of a
[ __ ] you thanks for fighting for me i
appreciate it well all right buddy go
have fun with your friends love you guys
that's so funny man great that's so
funny i love it love you buddy
wow hey all right it's about what i
expected it was it was almost like dogs
versus cats yeah same sort of thing i
think people were inclined to like to
stephanie well that was fun as [ __ ] um
go see me on tour savile
countercomedy.com this is probably the
first week of january or somewhere in
january uh if i haven't played yet la
the will turn on january 22nd san diego
the majestic on january 25 21st uh and
if i haven't gone through yet january
16th cleveland at the agora of the three
that i really want to shout out
salvocanocomedy.com and uh yeah i don't
know nice
all right we're good you unplug it uh
yeah i got tom steve dave i got uh uh
four color demons i thought i'd mention
yeah the motorcycle uh gang that i
started about seven years ago yeah it's
it's comic book based it's all uh nice
anybody can join yeah it's free we're
not making money off you the the crest
that you have is amazing you put it on
the motorcycle jackets and stuff people
like where we have like we have like
over 10 000 members and people have uh
meetups in bars across like in england
and like so there are like they call
them rallies but but uh no you don't
need to own a motorcycle you just need
to have seen a motorcycle uh and and
people get together and they have like
real like rallies and stuff like that so
it's called the four color demons and
and the websites i think
fourcolordemons.com and check it out
where can they listen to tell them steve
dave uh
that's anywhere else
tell them as in t-e-l-l-e-m yeah tell
them all right well uh
i still love you babe i still love you
taste buds they coming to the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two fools gonna
fight but only one food can be right
taste buds man yeah they're coming to
the mic i'm talking taste buds